military Communications tech industry
secrets and Maritime Transmissions these
are some of the communications that
experts say may be intercepted by a new
intelligence gathering and military
training facility in Cuba built in
partnership with China experts say China
is trying to replicate the US's Global
surveillance capabilities and Cuba could
play a crucial role in that plan the US
has always had the advantage because
we've had the geography and that's why
Cuba would be an important asset for
China so how does Cuba fit into China's
Global eavesdropping strategy and what
do China's other Spy Bases tell us about
how this one could look
both the US and China already operate a
number of listening posts around the
world as part of their signals
intelligence or sigint programs
that's the process of eavesdropping on
The Voice conversations text messages
emails location signals and data
Transmissions that fly around the world
constantly in June U.S officials said
China had reached an agreement worth
several billion dollars with Cuba the
deal would allow the island nation to
build a new military facility capable of
electronic eavesdropping a hundred miles
from the Florida Keys Beijing and Havana
have both denied the planned facility
but U.S officials say China and Cuba
already jointly run four eave shopping
stations on the island and experts say
this is just the latest chapter in a
long history of Cuba's eavesdropping
capabilities
Russia used Cuba for decades because it
was the one place that they could build
a uh a listening post and collect a lot
of the data from the United States James
Bamford has written five books on
National Security and intelligence
agencies and previously worked for PBS
and ABC he says that a Chinese listening
post on Cuba would have a very clear
mission one of the key things you want
to do is eavesdrop on on satellites
because so much information is
transmitted
up to and then downlink from satellites
these satellites convey much of the
world's military diplomatic and
Commercial information they orbit about
22 000 miles above the Earth at a fixed
point over the equator mostly above the
Atlantic Indian and Pacific Oceans
Bamford says China has only been able to
tap into satellites over the Indian and
Pacific Oceans from facilities in the
spratly islands and great Cocoa Island
but listening into Communications over
the Atlantic Ocean is where Cuba comes
in I mean the way the trainers were
doing basically you need a very large
area in your building satellite dishes
or there could be 90 feet across and
then you a lot of times will put it in
the ray dome which looks like a big golf
ball covering both protecting it from
the weather and hiding the location of
where you're targeting these facilities
can range from a single satellite dish
to over a dozen having more dishes
allows the station to Target multiple
satellites at once Bamford says one U.S
listening Post in Japan can Target 8 000
signals from 16 satellites there's a
huge amount of data and you need a large
number of satellites to do that and then
once you've collected that you've also
got to demodulate it you've got to in
other words turn it from satellite data
into Data that can be understandable
this large amount of data is then
filtered to focus on specific types of
communications Bamford says that unlike
the US which mainly targets military and
diplomatic Communications
China is primarily focused on Commercial
eavesdropping they really are interested
in in technology and there are enormous
amounts of technological Communications
going back and forth to Silicon Valley
and so forth but satellite dishes aren't
the only type of sensor but China has
established in its other spy stations
around the world this satellite imagery
shows a type of Direction finding
apparatus called an elephant cage or
villain Weber there are huge antennas
there could be a quarter mile across and
they're they've got 360 elements the
poles basically wires on them in a
circle and the whole idea is when
they're trying to listen for a signal
that signal will hit one of those
elements one of those wires a
millisecond before it hits another one
and that way they could tell what
direction it is this information is
particularly useful for tracking
Maritime activity with Cuba
strategically located to pick up signals
along the U.S east Coast so if they're
trying to listen for an American
submarine in that area and the submarine
comes up and it sends a burst
communication it'll be able to collect
that information and find out the
direction and then they'll triangulate
it by having a listing posts other
places that have a similar type of
antenna and then you could triangulate
it and find out exactly where that
submarine is
as tensions between China and the U.S
grow intelligence gathering will
continue to play a key role in The
Diplomatic Military and Commercial
rivalry between the two Nations
and while experts say Cuba's spybase has
significantly improved China's
eavesdropping capabilities U.S officials
say they are confident in their ability
to meet their security commitments in
the U.S and abroad